we are required to activate building
please the room by the door for escape
the staircase please hold both and
rousing place the stairs are wet or
slippery if anyways unable to use stairs
please allow the others to exit Ruby
before they go to the fire escape door
where they can be given assistance our
assembly point will be in the public car
park at the side of the Civic sweet
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect you any belongings please do not
return to the building till given
permission to do so by council staff
okay apologies from absence we had one
some weeks ago from John Mason one yes
feed from Leslie butcher and
unfortunately Jerry Gibson has had to go
home sick tonight so he's giving his
apologies non members attending be calm
I guess and minutes of meeting held on
the 8th of sep tember depend if if that
is a true record I wasn't here but I
don't know if nothing sighing if I the
name besides okay yeah yeah don't think
it sorry later on any room decorations
of interest from anybody right well
let's move on to item 6 item five then
the Community Safety Partnership tiger
making in light of the statements been
issued today by essex police i'm not
sure if you had sufficient time to
really evaluate some of it of it
but perhaps you could start off and by
explaining to towards here where you
feel our mode of operation is now how
we're going to operate watch what we
gotta do and we will spin off of what
you tell us well I mean just put in
perspective the original assistant
director Joey Owen Hughes who is
responsible for this areas of Syria left
the council's employment so even been a
trend transition let's tie so I won't
profess to be fully up to speed move
them with everything but you know
realizing there are some issues
potentially terms and palaces ability to
deal with certain things like antisocial
behavior which they which they deem us
making this low-level if there's no
threat of harm or you know risk in that
sense so look somewhat there as far as
I'm aware what they're sort of attitude
is to that is to refer these things on
to other organizations including
Street Council problem we have is that
we also don't have much in terms of
resource in order to to deal with that
the question we have though in terms of
what we do now to business planning is
is that our place to to do more of that
or or should it be on place to pressure
the police to do more or other agencies
and those are the kinds of things we
need to we need to look at and there's
anything there are any simple answers to
this I don't know what members wanted to
explore in world I mean I think that are
the first question I England that I've
gotten enough pot around you know help
what stage or how long do you think it
will be before we get an assistant
director will take responsibility for
some of this area where the assistant
director is is being it's out to
internal and I'm which closes up in
opera week a bill attempt to leave per
set looking at your lemur so that we've
I think we've got a few internal
applicants ready to see what happens
there and maybe pretend you interviews
this friday from entering past six
months like we did for the finance and
the the legal role refining funny
mention anyone would look to recruit a
full post externally we can't find my
eternal and
but that as you know could take some
time given notice periods interview
processes adverts on the usual the usual
process so it can be fairly quick its
internal or it could be several months
of is it in stone this is the answer to
virtual and have we established I mean
they've talked about low medium risk as
is be yeah of what point do we feel that
I mean we've already that you already
set up there we're limited on the
resources we have available to start
with where we're possibly looking at
this thing worse scenario three or four
months before we get potentially perhaps
a new ID are we looking to increase our
staff within the unit anyway and what we
do if this low medium risk is be
suddenly starts because there's no
action being taken by their ass or the
police it moves from being low level to
a much higher level and I'll throw that
in there not let the other boys up dear
amazing it gave it depends on what our
role is I mean in terms of statutory
role I think there's a duty to to be
part of the community safety partnership
but other than that there is no rosters
for us to determine what the level of
involvement we want with
by antisocial behavior the difficulty
the flip side then you could throw a lot
of resource into it and have that kind
of fairly responsive role now that there
was a dual breast of it which ops it
costs money and you have to prioritize
somewhere else the problem is if you're
seen as they've sort of fourth emergency
service is that is that a good thing or
a bad thing you know should this be the
police's rollin on that ship we have
invited the couple of Representatives
and police union representatives who
can't speak to the leader and deputy I
think my talk with us earlier on because
we're not particularly happy with that
response in terms of you know roofers
hand it over to our ultra you know there
should be there should be a more pomp
register let's say so so they don't just
divert you know calls and people on our
doorstep when we would not be done to to
deal with it so that's that's that's
happening does anyone if we won't want
Jack and we'll pick up in Estonia gonna
go on technique so if I still got back a
bit if he is all that's a monster truck
so I just looking at the doctor new to
any place you change forever and there's
a number of issues here before we even
get into why and one more for because I
would like to know where there's been a
consultation in all of this or or even
if your discussion we've got fun or any
other district to cover their about
their statement on this paper for
example they make comments like 1772
people visited riot police station can
do this comprises with as far for
president that's quite considerable
because better than is a division where
cause so you know I mean my one day many
more and of those visitors to radius
from county join yourself just 19 before
reporting the crime then there seems to
be their criteria it doesn't go on about
whether it's lot of property when the
ritter's issue
you know other issues which are placing
responsibility they're providing Dawkins
making statement knowing there's a
number of issues and it just seemed to
write this hot so gnarly 19 people
coming to commit a crime but it's more
to pleasing than just cry as we all know
but I'm really interested to know really
about the consultation process and hail
and what we've done and you say that
there's going to be a meeting i'm
pleased to hear that because i want to
know what we're going to respond to this
statement because it seems to me there
that is going to devote pieces those
they're going to make a joint
partnership between cars appointed
rockford with that number you couldn't
police a section nevermind two districts
and it's interested to know or
understand how that's going to work and
that's really wanna know before we even
get into where I responsive is on the
environment actors you know has got
statutory responsibilities house in
about statutory responsibilities and all
of those overlap with antisocial
behavior that's that's we know there but
so what easy the police are looking at
for us to deal with because we come on
to the confrontation the personnel
issued as insurance is equipment as you
pointed out this early response and all
the rest of it who records all of this
and if there is a taking of details we
don't have access to well the police
have in terms of pay attention so I'm
only interested to know where this
consultation is go in a waiting on just
a form so i can write a place that it is
riding off to us because if it's so i
think is this counter going to take a
strong lead in this and let the public
know where we see because i could see as
a counselor don't we have people coming
to member a number of issues and i don't
see that's my responsibility so I would
say that really so it's a mixture of
number of questions but is
yeah I'm not sure if I got all the
answers to be honest the Chairman I mean
consultation I'm not sure that was why
and if there was it was before my time
so I'm not I've not seen by myself so we
let consulted on these changes is is
something we can really find out I'm not
sure if any other members have that
information I'm not I've certainly not
seen anything in terms of you know when
these debts come from terms of visitors
to Riley you know 19 crimes are
authorized to it I don't know okay it's
their document they produce this today
announced it to to the world so to speak
and in terms of taking things back to I
think it'd be helpful this committee to
ya through Michelle's limiting it the
rest of it and then even particular
questions you want raised with with
those senior officers at that meeting
your health origin person job good gear
come you don't normally walk round to
the police station to report the crime
do if you're in your car and you don't
have a mobile phone with you and you
notices something you may stop at the
police station but ordinarily contact
the police by telephone yeah I mean
either police's defense there you know
they've got severe cuts hitting them
they're there they're undertaking an
exercising prioritization you know it
costs money to keep the station open and
they can divert that whistles elsewhere
and having smoking heard from releasing
yeah crime commissioner you know he's
moving away
beats and police stations over what the
police it has changed since since the
other that because I'm it may have
changed but it's a signal of weakness if
people see the police stations closed
down that rightly assumed there's less
police officers in the area and there
are more at liberty to do they learn
possibly your baby I imagine the
statistics repair otherwise but I'm here
to answer that can I ask Nick where
where do we stand in relation to other
councils is there going to be a joint
counsel approach to the police or are we
going to be doing our own little 111
conversations or is there going to be
some some joined up thinking because if
we're being asked to take on some of
these issues I mean our bed partner is
his castle point so how are we going to
deal with with them and are we going to
have a joint meeting or is it just going
to be Roger talk to them then they're
going then castlepoint in talks to the
police you know this is this is where
I'm getting concerned that we're being
used as a straw every time and you know
there's no sort of joined up thinking
and we can wind up trying to justify my
situation that we none of us are geared
up to deal with that's right so there's
a good puncher I mean whatever we do I
think there's got to be a degree of
hardship working there is this community
safety partnership with castle point
it's only right that you know even work
together to ask sort of appropriate
questions of the police and also I
potentially worth join me on any any
solution doesn't make sense sometimes
and lots of different people doing feel
the same thing so they could be
something that Professor but have we got
anything playing 22 well I don't know
because he is your attitude I'm not
sound the Community Safety Partnership
know growing Brown does I'm not sure
where you're going to stand on this I've
not seen any literature through there if
anyone else but it certainly it's
another thing you know my role here
partly is to in the maintenance to take
away some things from today that I can
take back you know to these senior
officers to me Community Safety
Partnership to graham Brown and whoever
of to say these are the issues how we
never get to do with them and I think
that's a valid one what's the community
safety partnerships view of all this
there should be that kind of coordinated
regards this is affecting kasbah point
and us in the same way I'd imagine how
should we or should we do with it so I
was reading my fake United Arab early
cambrian still has a police station i'll
be remain American so it won't be
effective cast for the same wherever
they're facing my trip we took the
reasoning on stairs I never liked em IQ
click file in it without comptia precise
figures it's initially the letter
originally from the system harmon poets
from there the Assistant Chief Constable
was written on the twenty-second of June
janome and that was to the chief
executive mr dying the body this was
going to happen right when were you
first aware of this it's a that's funny
personally first the way when John Mason
contact me directly about the incident
by you aware behind time whether or not
the assistant director did it my had any
action on this was their actions alone
quietly so do not do them properly isn't
local would you have seen if would you
expect I've seen it before coming to
this meeting if there was action being
taken really so you wouldn't expect to
see something around this on bits point
across this letter was written on the
second second of the 22nd of June and we
can actually make the cspa was it simcha
lie which and they didn't mention it to
talk about that meeting either with that
surprise you that wasn't made to do that
me too now the CSP one in terms of you
know my role you it's just sort of take
things right until you know today maybe
risk no Bob CSP so they had a crazy is
he able to do them and how they work
what he'll what they do what be what the
reporting the mines are if there is
something that comes out and here it
goes through and all the rest it's GC on
in your yourself yeah is a reason why
the portfolio hopeful attend tonight
goodness and pretty noble measurement I
thought they gladly go out today I'm
just going to sense that we're not
really going anywhere with the questions
at all and ask questions about Arthur
you know the answers it's okay well we
better try as I said what I rather than
looking at the answers sighs helping
raise your expectations in there like
why can't I can't do is take away you
know these points and you know it sounds
like there are I think there is a
genuine concern Lee from from all of us
as to hell as a community we are going
to address these issues that by and
large are being dumped onto us yes we've
done just as a
quick oversight we don't seem to have
our own house in order with regard to an
ID who will be responsible for this we
don't have the resources within our own
system to deal with ASB we don't have
the right people to deal with our USB
because I'm not quite sure or is be low
risk is and medium risk them when its
own suddenly becomes criminal damage and
how we fit into to all this system we
don't seem to have a system that if
there are our issues and we pretty much
know that was gonna being dumped the
arrow spices in the evenings or a
weekend we and if the police are not
going to be around we done and we are
going to be the front line so to speak
we've got to tell the public this is the
situation you face what the situation is
when you've spun to Castle Point all the
rest of it and how we're going to deal
with it how we're going to record this
it has there been an increase I mean we
know we've got issues iam in rochford
and Clements all already and I don't get
the impression they're going to go
downhill I don't know if there's any way
that we're recording these issues I
understand from conversations with our
counselors yesterday that there's
already concerns about our potential
vigilantes set up in certain areas in in
rockford because of love level is BS is
described but that to my mind sets a
downward spiral because you know as well
as I do if a resident gets hurt then
we've got an even bigger problem on
their hands so yeah I mean it's the hot
they're publishing is needs to be worked
out you know what as I said at the start
or is our role as a council in this are
we you know are we at extremely going to
be like a fall for agency service and
then be available to a while or seven
days a week to police this after we go
and turn up on site and then raise their
expectation in terms of dealing with the
issue and having some powers to do
something and there's one in the
spectrum or is it something completely
different which is where about where we
are now and what is it volleyball is all
about what do we want to provide
residents you know we wait until then
then from there or not if we are you
know you know what will how do we do
that what you mentioned earlier chairman
in a partnership approaches something
which needs to be looked at you know the
police I'm saying they're totally
walking away I don't think romantic
social behavior they're just they're
just there needs to be kind of strong
evidence that there's you know threat of
risk of harm thence otherwise I just get
up they can't place priority on it
they've got other things which lead in
more serious that they have to attach me
first you know they prob be a real time
but we need to think very carefully what
is our role it can you know community
safety what what what is it we want to
do in that respect and you know if we
get down on a certain line you know then
the resident will you know the police
will come to rely on us and the rest of
its real
to realize you know in order to do
something and have we got the resource
and ability to actually use those powers
in the right way and in force if
necessary for police on there at the
moment in the party has been very much a
kind of monitoring role and if something
happens in the police would have come in
and finish the job off so he needs we
need to be really careful and keep our
waitress yeah thank you ma'am this
little from what I've seen book season I
believe can be clicked station and I
won't have a front counter ever ever so
but we know we're in rockford and Carson
point across to go see the police I just
wonder the mentality where an
organization that can tell me if there
were 6601 people visiting self in police
station in two months I wouldn't they
just tell you their pledges to stick so
something a bit bizarre to me and this
bear what we prepare about their press
for the past and dance if we are gonna
go down the road of trying to run an
antisocial behavior team or unique or
force the first thing you should know is
what powers do need now we've got those
powers and secondly how much it would
cost I I think it'll be very hard for us
to to pay for it but I think you need to
know what what's of enforcement needs
numbers of people are kind of thing I
think I don't know if we know yet this
community policing team of about nothing
10 people and for peer
4pcs owners we're going to have a pretty
tough agenda of protecting the public
from home preventing and I'm bringing
criminal to justice engaging the public
and ensure the public of satisfied of a
silver so received in love with that but
I think I don't know about you don't
know yet holding the inspector in-charge
about taking the sergeant's defenses but
I think if we're going to have any
success it's fun to deal with these
things we need to have a bad good
relationship the votes of individuals
must not be important follow them I
thought you were saya there mr. Blythe
sharing about watch wasn't taking the
class among kind of thing I think
facebook is now Facebook's of two edged
sword you could you could get
information hopefully if it got human
duplicity not just councils for officers
move on us on Facebook see what's going
on the bats of could sorts of
information but I just get about people
to get very angry very upset and you can
include leading expanders about that
starts the thing so the big group got a
bear mind below i'm at New Age part of
that I don't think it's gonna work but I
think the cutbacks and at work I'm gonna
have a port for this service but I think
we're going to struggle to do any sort
of behavior however whatever happens I
think the only one I don't think the
answers lie accounting therefore I fit
the answer lies in central government
and I think if we're concern we should
feed into my subscribe to our MPs of
course ethics so this isn't working two
months austerity you know change your
plans
Mike did you welcome back one for
anything yes after so i agree with them
and cups of black particular letter
parka Slater's entirely essex / lisa
apparently or will work closely with
partners to deal with this who will they
be dealing with in the absence of an
assistant director i think it support
enough that it should be dealt with at
least that director level at this point
well i mean which is yourself i think an
effective yes I mean that that's that
could easily be done and I mean we are
already linked with increasing the
number of times on this another other
matters that whoever
area commander of the whole healthy and
he's he's quite sensible chairman Lee he
sees the one who's coming down to Me
Lean activity of pilgrim results I just
think it's important that we are very
proactive in the consultation over this
around partnership working because I
think maybe in the past we've been
waiting for it to happen and I think
it's important we we tell the police
what we need and what the problems are
there's all this the young community
show around we were going to have a
habit ready police station which I
shooting the police have probably
forgotten about if they're closing the
counter service which was made up up a
bit ineffectual I think I think there's
you just wonder if the police are at the
levels these decisions will be taking
taken are aware of the partnerships been
in place already which are failing it
seems so they it's very important that
director level is involved proactively
at this stage what I'm happy to and you
know try and say that forward and I
think you're right we have to be
proactive and I think with a lot of
things you can work smartly on these
things some lovely Collison see the
police officer these is very good on the
mall and he will be open to sort of
innovative solutions so it may be that
different eternity things before so yes
something that simply can I suggest Nick
and then I'll get everybody up chintia I
mean obviously this is only just landed
on your lap yeah you're you're very much
aware of it following your meeting with
the police and subsequent appointments
of IDs or how it goes could we ask you
to come back in December and give us an
update on where we stand if there's no
opportunity to to give us an update
before hand but i'll give members the
opportunity to ask Nick any other issues
you want to raise that can be addressed
that he can come back to us with weave
in particular the December's session
okay like it been some [ __ ] already
been to but I'll come back to visit us a
joint thing really known such a bad
liability with all of this and I'm
really interesting there we go because
there's a Kip tell you probably know mr.
Pilkington case who is the woman who
killed herself and the dog out there and
that like someone and like a legal
responsibility on everybody about our
bility we can't like normally and
ultimately there were suggestions here
that they're wrong because what the Pope
into case Wars was a woman and a doctor
who many of you every year and I killed
it so cuz I didn't have any support my
name so she even had big words as money
and the place of solvent extension and
in there there was a suggestion that you
know if you don't do something you
couldn't that be corporately a mess or
Cobra metal if you know if it was no
blood bility wish I so they put a lot of
pressure on everybody about because of
the Pilkington place about anti-social
behavior and that seems to have been
pushed aside then we had when the only
socially win the Qantas all around came
out
2003 it introduced the CDR pages the
crime disorder abduction fantasies which
then ultimately got changed to the CIA's
piece now hold on the chp from a
different role for the council but not
this council from no cattle and unfair
dogs go this council Penobscot as a 10
cats the parish council but i sat there
in these meetings a base that has been
told not involved I was being told what
was going on an odd report back so it
been diluted from these sort of man and
its p situation okra strategic
partnership with a [ __ ] RP you know the
governance and we had all the partners
trouble the strategic another poem is
coming together deciding about any so
quit looking at monies and and webbing
allocate resources and what we're going
to do was a big flame and everybody was
involved all the different authorities
and it was magic it work well now i
understand classroom i'll be used to
control the cost advantage coming to me
we seem to divulge their where we
haven't got a serious we can call it
this is because no one's on me because
they devote that it's over that babies
are doing that's what i want to know is
where we have this sort of my actions we
had all this power bishop we had all
this discussion and someone regardless
or a concept never got nothing at all
I'm sitting here we don't have anything
and I mean we ever got an important
meeting you're coming up this is not
personally but for their family the
signature review committee the ions that
we were going to discuss all of this
we've got no other representation or
even from the police it can't ask any
questions and all you can do is take
back what we're discussing and for me it
shows how important this issue is in
respect of our management the police
everybody else because obviously in our
case which is pulse in the back of we're
all sitting there saying how I walk and
that's the question and I fixed orbit
let and to be frank with isn't well I
think I think you've got the juice near
going to ness anybody else has got any
other points they want to write we have
you've gone one we ever we but we do
have some serious genuine concerns after
where as a council we're going to go
into hell our reservoirs up in the fuel
okay we know this potentially is a
low-crime area nor rest of it but there
is a whole raft of issues most of which
I things have been bull up to you this
evening that we would like a dress or
answers to or some sort of guidance as
to how the council the police and or
other partners wherever they might be
going to work together in the future
because you know that we as a district
council to me do not seem to be geared
out how to take on what is expected of
us out our staff recording and all the
rest of it people who are authorized to
take action whatever that action might
be so might and then will you learn when
we want to next topic but it's probably
ridiculous it off I just want to add I
think it's very important that we
urgently come up with a short term
action plan on this at the moment there
are problems being reported the police
are repairing or turning out to what
they regard as low level and social
behavior although some people regard it
was higher than that and I under the
moment the public don't know where to
turn to is the doctor the Chairman says
it could turn to vigilantism certainly
on facebook page and I think it's very
important we are able to sell the public
where to go even if we're taking the
piece that in the short term we're going
to come back to you anyway I think it's
important you think I think you're right
these monuments are quite and greener
cereal and they do especially the pass
it in the back if I put it so crudely is
that you know it's not right that
residents push repetitive post because
it's not their fault yeah they mercy you
know Deena threats of harm and different
levels of you loaded with top down
ginger type stuff too serious from the
beauties and if you are the resident
whatever it is it feels you feel it so
the worst thing to do is be pushed
repetitive post get out now its response
line and then it goes nowhere if the
wait three days for a response clearly
that's not that's not on it but the
question is how do we always are rolling
that you know is it do we push the
police to do more do work upon [ __ ] or
doing gear up our results is to spend
money on it and have a fully fledged
team that can do that's also not done
and I don't know where that lies at the
water that's something that but I mean I
should I say now can i regress unique
that when you've got anything that you
can tell particularly this committee but
the counselors in general something is
is made into the public domain so that
at least we know where we're all going
Joey you go so it's baseball the
observations thought really but I think
generally I mean crime this crime as in
statistics and evidence of crime but
it's also the issue of perception of
crime actually I think largely Essex
Police another police forces obably have
failed miserably to tackle the
perception Crom anti-social behaviour
when you go knocking on people's doors
are elections RNA it's the one thing
that comes up repeatedly something
that's never really been put to bed and
actually I see this as a bit of an
opportunity really for the council to
change that perception because actually
the figures are like but that's not the
perception people have generally
people's perception is anti-social
behaviour is a huge issue there's a lot
of it it's never being tackled it's not
important to the police and there might
be some truth in that
perhaps Michael talks about the fact
that the police don't bother attendings
a cause so perhaps now this is a time
for the council to take it you know in
hand and change people's perception
maybe that should be the first thing we
look to tackle because in terms of crime
reigns as the chairman boards now is we
will know is quite a low area for crime
but is that message actually getting out
to people you know because already I've
been looking on facebook as we speak you
know this this subject is all over
facebook like a rat rules in it talks
about being slated as we speak and i
think maybe the council's first i'm
looking perhaps a shifter and plan
should be to try and tackle the people's
perception of anti-social rather than
try and actually do with the statistics
in the Dean of em across have more
questions and they'll go I think needs
pretty much just do it brian j
increasingly call it a day i think new
technology will help a lot of this body
cameras CCTV etc even these and where
you can actually take photographs of
people doing things blah blah blah
probably see all the questions that we
are
but once again i will see if we haven't
got anybody in charge of it because we
need to start somewhere and I think we
should be tried as quick as possible to
get something in charge so that what I a
momentum can start because obviously at
the moment we're just shooting in the
dark on where you know if there's no
leaving time because we haven't got
anybody there that can take our
questions forward all start the board
process rolling we just talked about one
another I think Nick's got that one bro
I just make it clear I don't like we've
got a nobody in antisocial behavior we
have lots of almost hottest as you
closely it was our antisocial behavior
coordinate experience chap and it just
got me to save the partnership he does
come on and I think it does respond
hence the whole one incident was was
responded to those holiday at the time
so they said there is there just to come
back to Council Norman's point about the
people okay so it's a valid point but I
think in all of this if again I'm not
defending the police but they would say
their approach to it that sort of series
the threat kind of angle would hopefully
pick up those serious cases like council
or mentioned which would which wouldn't
be you know responded to one just be
left well yeah but when we have concerns
nikli it's going to fall in the crack
baby that's an ex air concerns I think
that where are the parameters for some
of these things and at the moment there
are no parameters it seems to buy lies
most of us at the police oh well this is
not what we're going to do anymore up to
you well that's right but so tell me
looking at ism lawyer
juicy of care you know again you gotta
build it with care because the more you
do havoc on the more the expectation
Rises that you are there to do it if you
fire off matter then if it comes on you
but at the end of the day how residents
expect somebody to do it as I know
they're therein lies a question Jackson
that he got one more question for you
normally now but it's a long question
not seriously is the concern in as much
as I'm sitting in this injuries and
policy of my own feelings very all I
don't really want that to me but it
seems to me the words and authority seem
to be worrying about all of this and a
police or not it seems to me that
they've made a statement over to you and
here we are seeing discussing this and
it seems as though it's a tail wagging
the dog and I haven't seen anyone you
heard any talk i'll come back to the
consultation we've set any disguise
Harry could be dealt with now we can
sign it forward any form of strategy you
know there's been nothing at all that we
can discuss you know I mean my own
personal experiences is that you get
maybe get a number of minor as bees they
usually attached to serious I booze and
you know they're not linked to other
incidents we don't have that network we
don't have that software but the police
do and that's what used to happen and we
use any work Maria now and I'm not so we
shouldn't work place i'm not suggesting
that whatsoever but it seems to me that
we're working back to front now what
should be happening is we go back to the
old neighborhood action planes is where
the police not necessarily the enum not
suggesting that I ty Calder is once
buddy but we should be working closer
together using their existing policy
burn procedures and but now on sit down
talking about with it about no strategy
whatsoever or is it means Charlie
subpoena duces what we're asking that's
my boy
and we have that meeting sites of our
purpose because we know we're not happy
with every so there's gravity scheduled
at ease with Nicky's hopefully with
equity and terminations okay Chris last
one yeah good point journey about some
fear of crime explore looking the police
dr. Kate because I mean besides you
before the last and last 12 months in
the making and Albert area 179 burglars
which if you back there were 17 say
seventeen thousand nine hundred houses
in bailey and hullbridge that works out
to one of the New York you have superb
you 100 years which is kind of Lee
assuring I think I was thinking exactly
have plugged this up about dealing with
chewing gum and da best if it's a few
posters in the high street saying on
other words you get Vogel's in provide
the basis of getting filled with every
100 years or on average if you leave
your car in one of our child parks it
will get burned every so often i watch
out once a team of study every 18 years
something like that enough but my heart
with it away but other than that I'm
committing a certain yeah perhaps you
can have a word with communications
department well Nick and see see what we
can get an in the big wide world in all
sorts of areas in a bit like everybody
was saying the crime to getting up when
all the street lights go out the reality
is it didn't
well no but we are gonna use the Pacific
yeah I mean but there is one thing
realities and though there is an
underlying thing here that crime could
go up and we haven't got anything in
place to deal with it nor was that I
mean we pretty much knew any of us had
any dealings with the police over the
years we pretty much knew when the main
burglary time was and it isn't when his
[ __ ] dark so on that aspect there was a
certain amount of historical evidence to
say but this is an entirely different
animal anyway members can we move on I
think like we've given Nick enough to
get out fielder out concerns George is
one last thing I mean it is a counselor
horse-pond about the strategic approach
community so departure I think I'll take
myself onto one of those meetings to see
because only what they discuss and what
their approaches to these things to see
if they're you know firing on all
cylinders because I think there should
be some leadership there if that is a
strategic body date supposed to be
leaving these things yeah where's Alicia
there you know maybe they'll get some
good things it's just not written down
but I'll find out themselves okay knee
if we move on members do item number six
which I think really nick is is is back
to you and from here yeah i mean i'm not
going to go on too long on this is what
we see but so just a really sum up
absent members you haven't had the
pleasure of read
in part this is basically another code
alert coburg surveilling them as a
policy of authority like council when
amber Tate code works have aliens or if
they take over surveillance than they
need to do it very careful in under very
strict guidelines and a policy which we
have also got and the outside of that
policy in a final fitting looks way is
by this committee and it is also
independently inspected every two to
three years by the office of
surveillance commissioner who are
normally X high called judges so they
have no good stuff and they go through
everything to highlight fine-tooth comb
this legislation was intended for
terrorism and that kind of thing but
it's going to trickle down to us as well
so so we're inspecting got a very
favorable which I'm pleased to say the
commended members council that members
get involved in their hands general
oversight which is good the commended
the training and then they even
recommended us to another counter which
is good news there were some minor
amendments recommendations which emerged
from that report which I feel so
encapsulated towards the end of your
approval and at the same time and all
the update members online usage of
reaper IE where we seek to get an
authorization to carry out covert
surveillance we haven't had
options for the past few years now and
in fact are our own scope to you to do
covert surveillance is pretty limited
it's got to be for a criminal offenses
which character six-month custodial of
which we don't really have many from the
counter that we have powers to enforce
that carries that current sensor to make
the flight opinion a couple of other
social security type full defense is
about it but we don't really do any more
so we are a spare and user we do Reaper
well in the end of you testified but
there are a few few adjustments needed
every bite of the changes of personnel
few adjustments there so I'll leave it
at that if you've got any questions
members have entertainment the army i
think i must have been on this committee
i m-mean in years gone by we've been
down this road very much before has been
explained to us in detail from my
experience that you know that there are
the necessary alterations due to the
restructuring of the council name
changing responsibilities changing if
anybody else has got any questions you
want to ask of nick please go ahead i
think pretty much this is a routine
approval up operation languages that
chair that there is some training crime
you've not
home in January 29 30 i have nation
britain has to everybody microphone yes
you're free on the brave and i will
become speaker reviewed on there you
know he's been tried and tested his
qualities quite engaging so i recommend
you come on that it's quite an
interesting and half a dose session and
I'm so so hopefully worth your while
doing the community to recommend a
result that we enjoyed this if everybody
is in agreement then we been worrying is
these proposed that the committee
results us to know the council's annual
usage of right raipur however you want
to go in fact these proposed in the
Committee recommends to the council that
the amendments to the council's Ripper
policy set out in 4.1 above are approved
agreed literally thank you very much
thank you thanks think you're very
welcome to stay if you wish you famous
25 actually should get that to the LCD
on things type of starvation
thanks very much names I'd probably 30
jun it's babbitt super money's come back
to you all know son okay members if we
can move on to the key decisions
doctrine of it for lead on on this once
we work through my laptop will be broken
all this in person this is pretty
successful goals and 12 others yet today
and we all hated it we must you know yet
so i am well you need to take away okay
this is crazy when you up gory have
everything goes through it yeah right
keep sitting document and first one and
more first two are the two items that
you called in back in June July time and
there we would there will be decisions
coming on as to the second one obviously
because its support the assistant
director community and housing services
I can post so hopefully when that if
they put someone on friday that it might
start moving again on that one all right
the turning over the page 25 15 the home
strategy that was also on the kids
suiting document enjoy and among their
waiting for the new assistant director
housing I'm not planning starts no bed
on the stash 11 26 was it because no
that's the one yeah woman so you know
they don't want to do anything until
she's a chance to look everything so the
probe is a completely fictitious plate
to living I mean yeah I think you'll go
back further than optimal route I was it
would yeah yeah I mean probably more
realistic to look at the January by the
time she's had a chance to look
everything so the only new is shipping
items on there both Andrew loving
strategic partnership on prices advice
services contract this is when they put
out for tender the advice services
contract that you don't and then looking
at whether you say over or another
organization I want to take it off that
the decision has to be made in December
and this wives is there and then the
last one the 13-15 the voluntary sector
grants every year that's a regular one
on there and again the decision has to
be made in December yes so your foot go
back to the home statutory yeah because
I fiber what that is about is whether is
it do you think we've good sort of
housing from a social point of view for
the doing of housing in a development
plan point of view and the point is a
risk of not taking up taking the
decision it sets out the overarching
framework for dealing with housing
demand and house you need within the
district strategy will provide clarity
around the principles and arrangements
within 2,000 matters in the district so
I imagine it's going to be social
housing etc the whole
I'm not sure sure it goes as far as a
Marvin papi to smile feeds into it yeah
but this isn't makers portfolio hold of
a community side seaming start this
other one June just stepped into the
booze knows it I'll start to go back no
but now that was counting allocation
policy labov it yeah and that is still
ongoing this tool because the longest
Weather Machine it I think it's fair to
say that you know we are struggling down
here with the restructuring to to make
any headway and like these these items
are to us we've just seen with with Nick
you know as much as we will try and eat
our information and try and review some
of these issues it's fairly obvious that
the right plate line in the right place
should be honest for asking questions if
it were William got the answers for us
I'm not excited just a lot of good side
I went to a Finch field meeting this
morning own mark in order rest of it you
know that the department came in full of
information for the support loads of
actions it was firmly very positive so
we've got a new assistant director in
there you know who went why this is how
do I would walk home White House
involved in
wonder you have but it does that but it
is going to be positive you know someone
damn no I say I think there are a number
of areas Jack that we try to ask
questions and it new portfolio holders
new assistant directors is making life
difficult for us to elicit information
you know we will have to do the best we
can this year to do this and hopefully
you know we will be able to elicit some
information I think that the meeting
which at that we Nick is sort of gave
him more questions and then he expected
to be honest I mean he just walked into
it we've just walked into over this a
dozen of us and one of him anything else
that on this key decision document if
not we'll move on to the work phone poll
and see what we got lined up for the
next meeting in even with a Michelin
star it's the ultimate ii review and
you'll see I say now a meeting in by the
next week basically to formulate
questions you know so we you know you
can tear questions and we can feed them
in I've got tentatively someone from
Essex County from planning enforcement
the waist addition we've got someone
from planning the team leader from
planning enforcement here ourselves
Environment Agency it declines me
he's giving me a bit I life but a lot
environmental health lined up and I'm
trying to get someone from legal at the
moment was that the liver but yet that
fear for the November one and then
December we've got we've just included
Nick coming back to you as well um but I
would also think possibly some of those
things on the December one will get
pushed back and mrs. the assistant
director post that's why I recently had
the meaning for this meeting and we've
had to move them I think we might be
moving again neither is getting to be a
movable faced at one sonatine know sort
of i'm just going to call it because we
did ask if he could come back in this
effort here and that would obviously
affect your little rustic i think i
think is pull sick jack we're going to
be this year we are going to be busy
well we're trying to address them when
people are in position to answer the
question so we're going to put to them
it's now I mean you know Nick could
answer nothing tonight mosey took was a
succession of questions for us from us
to come back an answer and we found this
the other the other day with with June
and last meeting but one wearers with
Jonah jovi similar scenario but now
juggies gone after shall German a
complaint process to the council you've
got listed I mean that could be an over
that choice B because I that's a bit of
life process if we do it now I think
you're very safe put the book you know
you're linking two things don't really
go together um I'm hoping the complaint
process will come to the December
meeting I'm hoping
but there are other reasons why that one
might not cover but we come we can't tie
in a complaint procedure safely with is
B if we don't know what the promises of
our responsibility honest I hope you ok
Paul is McGann the mature is far meeting
will we be touching on the disruption to
the transport network the roads and the
railway if that's the area you want to
go down I mean it's basically looking at
the council's actions prior to the fire
and was there something we could have
done a little patience you know yeah we
didn't do that that's the issue yes I
know there was transported disruption
but the brief is really more about the
council's actions as we we couldn't once
if i was there that's what was going to
happen bone beat the lead-up to the
brother a lot understand that we have to
be very careful don't worry about what
we talked about now because that could
create issues further down the road but
we can talk up own question what
happened up to fire her ok you can't
actually discuss possible scenarios
after you know what was going to happen
beyond that sees to the processing okay
can you explain to me why something is
taboo for the review committee and
secondly can I ask I got your question
which is how many ties are on the slide
there now
yes only because it would become pnc and
it ties me we're not in public records
you're not going to discuss what
possibilities you would do to the side
you know that would have to be peeing so
could understand that and now retire yo
I understood there are loads of toys but
I like to be nice but you have a some
factual information submitted the
information I could pass on the train
every day twice a day you see there
Whitney Cameron oh well now you say that
I think I did try but I didn't get good
doctor just this is again just a
confirmation I can all know anyone on
the work plan it's got the missions
forum meeting damn as the third of
November yeah and on your emails this
call you've been sorted in for the 13th
of November before there's a meeting
yeah 14 let's be in the 14 box hope it
is in full so is it 13 that I've been
bubble third got to let me know them to
come on let's just check in I was cuz
I'm trying to build off see your door is
the fall yet to the phone booth
October's the informal one your 14th
amok times important one I was going to
do I'm 13 Tuvok tell either way it was
the hub of the year but they was very
idea about planning to residents so had
moved to 14 and that's why I think when
I've gone to put november in it's
Freudian slip returned another that know
it my all to you can can we also carry
by all taking Chris's question boy the
scenario that would create issues if we
start talking about what might happen in
future yeah but there's a difference
built my own boss
support a bit but of course work on us
factual legends its established facts
now but let's make sure we know what the
parameters are yeah because we don't
want to and we could we can ask these
questions on the next week yeah and and
we can then come back to us at the
meeting to test whether what we can ask
on with our lives such a trimmer am I
not going to get to the meeting next
week i will be at the meeting in
november but well i'm sure you can talk
to microwave exactly but i want i would
like to the actual update on how many
tires are on site Chris if you'd like to
send whatever you want to ask copy to me
or general just I just said yes it is
again number tires stop jogging then who
can kick fuller just now it's a polar
bottle who's going to keep coming you
know to the third you know I get ID'd
the only director I don't think I show
that yes oh yeah but there was the
county read the waist enforcement our
team leader planning enforcement
probably environmental health asleep
check on an hour there and they don't
try to get something from legal no I
tried to get environment agency but they
turned me down there just give me a ring
okay thank you but if there's anything
else Christi I'm sure that let me 10
none and when we discuss it on next week
and my fries for you and we have the
answers our way about our deduction okay
okay members well if anything else post
meeting at eight-thirty thank you thank
you very much